yo yo yo everybody it's gary vaynerchuk
and uh what an ask you a question see
what you guys think about this to get
your thoughts on this your take your
take your two cents Oh first of all a
little little gourmet library calm
action no I got a give a plug to Justin
and ever and those guys in gourmet
library be talking about much more about
2010 but um um small town rules that's
what I realized this happening here
see because of mobile and Twitter and
Facebook and Ustream and Tumblr and
YouTube and not or not all these sites
LinkedIn which is I've done a terrible
job and I've been jumping into much more
lately you know all these sites what
they've really done is they've connected
us right and what that's done is made
the word world closer right we always
talking about that we're more connected
than ever
well what happens when you're more
connected than ever when everybody knows
your stuff you're playing my small town
rules all of a sudden small town rules
are gonna be the economy the things that
made businesses small ones like the
grandparents in your world how hard they
work to build them the things that made
them successful you know like when the
baker the baker's dozen you know where
that came from the Baker actually gave a
crap about you and gave you a 13 donut
go to Whole Foods right now by 13 Donuts
see if they'll charge you for 12 that
kind of thing or number two when
everybody knew your business you know
for all of you that grew up in really
small towns 90 kids graduated in your
high school you know whatever happened
to that bar in town people knew you
couldn't really whip out your thong
during the thong thong thong thong song
like you could add a big you know spring
break because everybody in town would
know and so businesses and brands need
to understand that now we don't thing
under small-town rules where the one
person the one individuals voice is
greater than ever and so what I'm really
intrigued by is how this DNA of a small
town is gonna impose itself on this
massive world of ours and why that's
going to be such a massively competitive
advantage for the brands that actually
give a crap about their users the ones
that actually provide service the ones
that are actually good there's gonna be
an enormous weeding out in the next 10
years from the companies that don't know
how to care or incapable to
here or just two big shift and start
caring and so when you think about
small-town rules and the way a small
town is really run when everybody knows
your business please understand that
you're gonna start to need to apply some
of those rules into way you navigate
your business and your brand